NBA draft put your starting five yours
against mine you go first who's your
first uh first pick players now or
forever no all time Kobe you pick Kobe
first of course I had a Jordan yeah
seriously yeah I played with Kobe are
you being serious I'm I'm yeah you
picked Kobe over NJ write it down take a
picture and fax it up while you take
Kobe I got champ
okay so Shaq's my first pick now I got
Jordan
you would put Jordan in Kobe you can't
do that that's two two dude you sent us
my team sir
got your team I got my team Shaq okay so
you got Kobe and Jordan uh Kobe and
Jordan in the backcourt all right so if
you got Colby and Jordan all right if
you're gonna go play that game I play a
different game and I'll go keemat four
oh Akin I got LeBron at three
you're going down
all right hang on let me see what I'm
gonna do here so you got what you got
the Jordan girls in the small forward
okay so here's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna go
um
no I don't you kind of no
I gotta get somebody long and I'll go KD
at three
KD that's three I'll go
uh need a power forward
at Center I'm gonna go the late great
Bill Russell
may he rest in peace may you rest in
peace wow okay I'm gonna go at I can
switch them one or two but I'll go Steph
Curry
oh
and at my four I'm going with
[Music]
I'm going with Carl Malone at the four
you got him alone really
holy moly what do I have left I got two
right I can switch them up I can put
Durant you ain't gonna win a game no I
am it's going to be I'm gonna win again
good luck coming through though huh you
can't come through me what are you
talking about I got a Shack in the key
bro I got LeBron Kobe oh you can't you
but you can be Shaq's crap out of you
you're done yeah
all right so I'm gonna probably mix it
up and I'm gonna get some defense I'm
gonna get some defense because I don't
need to score at this point okay I'm
gonna get Dennis Rodman for defense
I'm mixing it up you can't make that
look
I'm thinking I win by the way let's see
what they say you're the pro I'm the
amateur you're the prom the energy how
many guys say his team beats Mighty Make
some noise
they like you more how many guys say my
team beat history
this is embarrassing
I picked Shaq you're not rooting for him
no you picked Dennis Rodman let's see
I'll see you picked
foreign
[Music]